hello there folks I'm Walter Brennan see
a kin this is top five who's the most
famous movie composer in history
not exactly a brainteaser it's of course
the legend himself John Williams and
today we count down his top five best
film scores a while back I asked you
guys about your own favorite film scores
from John Williams and I got a ton of
feedback if you want to join in on those
conversations or vote on polls about
what I'm going to cover on future shows
make sure you follow me on twitter at
awesome underscore Walter this was the
most difficult top-5 I've ever done mr.
Williams work speaks for itself and it
was extremely tough to keep it to just
five also when it comes to music
personal taste
vastly vary so keep all that in mind as
we count down the top five best John
Williams film score number five
[Music]
I'll admit I didn't grow up watching the
Harry Potter movies and only saw them a
couple years ago thanks to this guy but
I was always aware of and impressed by
the music starting in 2001 with harry
potter and the sorcerer's /
philosopher's stone williams was the
main composer for the series - the first
three film from the fourth movie on
other composers were used but Williams
main theme was kept intact as it became
a hallmark of the film's here capturing
the tone of a book through films much
less music can be extremely difficult
Hedwig seems somehow encapsulate wonder
mystery drama adventure and magic I
think it's vital to get the audience
into Harry Potter's world and from the
first note we are engaged
[Music]
years and years before seeing the film
they actually played this main theme for
a grade school band performance I can
remember being in transpired wanting to
go listen to the real version very few
movie themes made me imagine an entire
world without ever seeing the film this
did that for me and gladly I did
eventually see the moving pictures the
music was set to Harry Potter just speed
out one of the honorable mentions I went
back and forth on it for a long time but
Perry steamed one out let's move on to
number four
[Music]
if you saw part 1 of my top 10 best
Robin Williams performances video you
know I love hook and it holds a special
place with me well a lot of that has to
do with the amazing musical score to
this film hook came out in 1991 and was
directed by Steven Spielberg it starred
Robin Williams as Peter Pan all grown up
while rediscovering his former life in
Neverland at this point John Williams
and Steven Spielberg had teamed up quite
a few times already for some iconic
movies but I do think this score is
often forgotten when talking about the
best of his career imagination and a
childlike exuberance filled this score
to the brim with almost tangible emotion
what I love about the hook score is its
sense of playfulness mixed with an
unequalled feeling of adventure that has
yet to be matched by any of Williams
other scores Peter Pan rediscovers
himself in this movie and the music cues
for this rediscovery have never failed
to give me chills
[Music]
melancholy undertones even out a score
with a full set of powerful poignant
moment hearing in music the soaring
heights of Peters return to flight and
villainous dark lows of Captain Hook's
anger and vengeance continue to be maybe
the best part of this film
honestly the more I listen to this music
the more I love it this is Peter Pan
this is inspiring this is hook and this
music will never ever get old number
three
[Music]
Anjana Anjana
Indiana Jones is a 3/4 part film series
with the first movie Raiders of the Lost
Ark debuting in theatres in 1981
Williams was the composer on all four
films and added to his musical legacy
with one of the most recognizable themes
in the history of cinema the hat the
whip and the theme you can almost hear
the escapades of Indiana Jones just by
the playing of a theme it's something
that's slightly evolved through the
years and incorporated other memorable
melodies heard in Raiders and the Last
Crusade
[Music]
[Applause]
I was fortunate enough to see the score
played live alongside a screening of
Raiders of the Lost Ark by the Chicago
Symphony Orchestra and it's even more
impressive in person it's very difficult
to find one definitive theme at
synonymous with a single major movie
character as this is here with Henry
Jones jr. aka Indiana Jones what can top
Indy well two more scores number two
[Music]
this was pretty much a given maybe not
in the spot you expected but still a
given nonetheless Star Wars of course
hit theaters in 1977 and has become one
of the biggest phenomenons ever in pop
culture along with jaws and Close
Encounters of the Third Kind the score
for Star Wars really put Williams on the
map as a master of his craft he's
composed for every film in the series
except for last year's rogue one a Star
Wars story we all know and love the
opening crawl main theme that
accompanies the big episodes in the
series but the music of Star Wars is
much more than just that we have the
emotional binary sunset track that is as
iconic as anything and as the original
trilogy went on we got even more
incredible themes the Imperial March and
know this theme stick out as special
from that time period
when the prequel started years later
Williams did anything but phone it in
say what you will about the Star Wars
prequels lord knows I have but the music
was as amazing as ever and wasn't once
called into question Williams actually
built upon what came before with new
tracks that are nearly as iconic as the
ones from the original trilogy while
battle of the heroes is fantastic the
prequel song most people point to when
discussing those selections is the super
intense duel of the faith
[Music]
after Episode three came out they
released a special cd/dvd combo called
Star Wars a musical journey hosted by
the Emperor himself Dean McDermott I
wore that thing out watching the DVD and
listening to those tracks you really got
an all-encompassing look at the Star
Wars music from the first two trilogies
and it puts everything in perspective
for you very well as unbelievable as the
Star Wars music is there's one theme
that I like just a little bit better
as stated before these top five
selections were extremely difficult to
choose and order which means a lot of
great ones couldn't fit onto the main
list just about every score that John
Williams has ever done is an honorable
mention at least but before we get to
number one here are a few more of my
personal favorites
[Music]
and the number one best John Williams
film score is I can't help it I freaking
love this thing I think it's my favorite
movie theme period John Williams scored
the original 1978 film directed by
Richard Donner and starring Christopher
Reeve as the Man of Steel
the subsequent sequels and whatever
Superman Returns was supposed to be
still used his main theme and cemented
it as V scene for Superman while Hans
Zimmer's Man of Steel score may be the
most tolerable thing about that movie
the William score is still what most
people recognize when thinking of the
man of tomorrow even putting aside Man
of Steel Superman has had some amazing
themes the Fletcher Superman cartoon has
come to mind however there's a reason
why this is by far and away the best it
is the essence of Superman everything is
supposed to be is in this song
altruistic mysterious powerful honest
full of integrity with an optimistic
sense of destiny goodness Superman is
the ultimate good guy damn it Superman
[Music]
I love this music because it reminds me
of everything that is good despite the
terrible things that happen daily it's
important to remember that good things
happen every single day - I'm not saying
ignore the bad thing but our lives can
be much more tolerable when we keep in
mind that there is more good than bad in
this world and it's up to us to fight
the bad and uphold the good that's who
Superman is that's what this music is
that's why it means so much to me you
don't have to agree but at least
recognize that as much as we have the
potential for evil we also have an equal
and even greater capacity for good
Superman is all of us he's us on our
best day a reminder of what we can be
and together what we can achieve this
music captures all of that because that
is Superman I want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite John
Williams movie score what do you want me
to cover next in the show leave a
comment and let me know if you missed
the last two weeks go back and take a
look at my list for the top 5 best
nineties nicktoons and Cartoon Network
show also make sure you check out
awesome colleagues from yesterday where
we asked is season 6 of Game of Thrones
the best season yet follow me on twitter
at awesome underscore walter to take
part in more polls about what i'm a
countdown in the future come back next
week for a brand new episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you